like its predecessor the long-awaited
frozen sequel is a movie for children
but lots of grown-ups are still watching
it and if anything frozen to doubles
down on bits that seem aimed squarely at
adults here's a look at some of the most
memorable moments only croon ups noticed
this is it the moment you've been
waiting for Elsa finally comes out of
the closet just kidding she definitely
doesn't but frozen to does throw in a
scene that seems to hint that Elsa could
possibly be gay even if it mainly just
comes across as Disney throwing a bone
to fans who were hoping for some
concrete proof of her sexuality in the
film Elsa and company venture to an
enchanted forest in the hopes of lifting
a curse that has left the North Ultra
and an errand alien army unit trapped in
the forest for over 30 years while
staying with the North ultra Elsa sits
by a fire with a young North alder woman
named honey Marin but to have a
conversation about the spirits in the
forest and they learn that they share a
bit of history thanks to a song Elsa's
mother sing to her when she was young
their interaction comes across as a very
flirty meet-cute and while it may fly
right over kids heads any adult can
interpret this as Disney's very safe
attempt at trying to hint at Elsa
sexuality ultimately their interaction
goes nowhere and they don't speak again
for the rest of the film making the
tension-filled scene something of a
disappointment for the fans who are
hoping for Elsa's big coming-out party
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has been a
major cash cow for Disney naturally this
sort of success has started to influence
the rest of the studio's offerings as
everyone wants a bit of that MCU magic
for themselves and frozen to is no
exception very early in the movie there
is a big battle scene between the
arendelle army and the North ultra this
is followed by a ton of action scenes
far more than the first frozen film
frozen to is practically an action movie
and most of the action feels very big
and MCU esque
then there's the direct reference near
the end of the film elsa becomes frozen
solid as a result any magic she created
begins to disappear this includes Olaf
who begins flurrying as in pieces of
snow start flaking off of them and
floating away it looks exactly like the
dusting that occurs in Avengers in
finna be war and at one point Anna even
cradles the disintegrating Olaf and her
arms just as Iron Man cradled spider-man
you half expect Olaf to say I don't feel
so good mr. stark before he disappears
completely one of the film's big reveals
is that the arendelle Ian's soldiers in
the North Ultra who engaged in a battle
34 years prior are still living in the
Enchanted Forest
that's pretty incredible both that they
went that long without killing each
other and also that they were able to
find enough food to stay alive for over
three decades but their survival isn't
the most impressive thing about this
ordeal now that would be the Aaron
DeLeon Army's clothes when Elson company
meet Matthias and the rest of the
soldiers they're all still wearing their
uniforms you know the uniforms they were
wearing 34 years ago that implies that
they have no other clothes which means
they've worn the same thing every day
for decades and they're still as crisp
and clean as the day arendelle marched
off to battle kids will pay little
attention to this but adults might
wonder where they can invest in some of
those most durable duds we don't know
exactly what honour and Kristoff get up
to in the bedroom but frozen to makes it
clear that the new queen of arendelle
has at least one major kink at the end
of the film some of the characters dress
up in some fancy duds to celebrate
honest coordination the clothes look
great but Kristoff hates them finding
them uncomfortable you get this for one
hour Kristoff tells Anna that's okay
ahna purrs I prefer you in leather
anyway on a you naughty girl well kids
will think that Anna is simply making a
cute reference to Kristof's regular
leather jerkin their parents will get
the joke lights go out on I like to get
a little freaky this is awkward that's
not the only racy comment in the scene
either after the exchange Olaf who
similarly dressed up remarks I'm shocked
you can last an hour and if you don't
get that one well ask your parents maybe
Hamilton and Glee star Jonathan Groff
who voices Kristoff didn't get a solo
song in the original frozen but frozen
to made it up for him in the sequel
Groff belts out lost in the woods one of
the film's most memorable tracks sure
Groff's performance is unsurprisingly
spectacular but what really makes lost
in the woods shine is its product
the number doesn't just evoke 80s power
ballads it's also staged exactly like
something you would have seen on classic
MTV with a few shots ripped directly
from Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody thrown in
for good measure
the whole thing is outlandish enough to
be funny for everyone but only adults
will understand what lost in the woods
is parodying that's by design in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
Groff says it's really kind of a gift
for the adults watching the movie the
kids are laughing too but the adults are
the ones that are really in on the joke
yes it's true in frozen - Elsa and Anna
wear pants as co-director Jennifer Lee
points out that makes sense as the
filmmaker put it - the Los Angeles Times
of course you're going to wear pants
when you hear the words enchanted forest
frozen - is a rough-and-tumble adventure
and it's heroes are princesses they
should be allowed to wear whatever they
want and yet over the course of Disney's
history that hasn't always been the case
aside from Mulan and Aladdin's Princess
Jasmine every other Disney princess has
been confined to dresses or skirts even
Anna and Elsa were stuck in long flowing
gowns in the first frozen and only got
to wear more practical attire when the
sequel rolled around according to Walt
Disney Animation Studios president Clark
Spencer switching up the duo's wardrobe
was a way to bring modern sensibilities
into a fairytale world and a
proclamation that there is more than one
way to be a princess kids probably won't
notice the change those of us who grew
up on classic Disney features though we
know it's a big deal
frozen - is full of nods to other movies
especially other Disney films but the
movies target audience is going to miss
at least one of them do you know many
children who are familiar with the
7-year itch the 1955 comedy starring
Marilyn Monroe yeah we didn't think so
Disney's animators snuck in a sly
reference to the film anyway the 7-year
itch is the movie in which Monroe stands
over a subway grate as wind from a
passing train lifts her white dress it's
one of the most memorable images in film
history
well frozen 2 has a similar scene when
the wind spirit Gale is playing with
Olaf the snowman's bottom half billows
out just like Monroe's outfit
Olaf even calls the experience of
delicious echoing the line that Monroe
utters during the iconic scene
do you feel the breeze in the subway
it's too much to be a coincidence and
it's a reference that's going to go
right over most kids heads check out one
of her newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite Disney movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]